KEVIN FIALA WATCHES IT IN.
TRYING TO CONNECT WITH MATT
BOBO
AND IN.
IT.
THEN HE HOLDS
MURPHY. NO QUESTION HE
CHANGED DIRECTION.
YOU CAN IN.
AND IT'S UPTHE
THERE.
AND AGAIN, GOING AND
COMING TO OUT. THAT.
I KEEP GOING BACK TO THE SAVE
M.
HE SMILES LIKE MOST OFK OUT.
OBVIOUSLY YOU WANT TO HELP AS
MUCH AS YOU HE
CONTINUES.
BATTLE.
AND I AM OKAY WITH MY DECISION.
YOU KNOW, I THINKUT THE
BLACKHAWKS GAME CONTROL.
SEVEN.
HE IS THE JETS AND
CAPITALS ONE AGAINST AWAY.
CARRYING IT BEHIND THE NET.
HE HANDS IT OFF INAVED.
>> GOT SOME GREAT
SAVED WILD.
PUCK DOWN LOW AND HE HAS AIS
LITTLE BIT OF TIME THE WIDE.
2:15, ALEXX.
TO NOW KEVIN
MINNESOTA.
>> YOU KNOW, IT IS A FITTING
AND FREDDIE GAUDREAU, CONNECTINE
FOFO